so during yesterday's White House
coronavirus press briefing there was a
truly chilling moment that needs a
little bit of explanation Donald Trump
at one point literally stepped up to the
podium and would not allow dr. Anthony
Fauci to answer a question about
hydrochloric win' hydroxychloroquine or
chloroquine this one of many possible
therapeutic treatments for coronavirus
that is currently being tested and
instead of explaining the whole
backstory first I'm just gonna play the
video for you and then I'm gonna give
you the whole story after that so weigh
in on this issue of hydroxychloroquine
what would you think about this and so
dr. pouchy stands there looking
uncomfortable and Donald Trump makes it
clear doctor foul Qi doesn't have to
answer meaning doctor foul Qi should not
answer that question and then another
question gets yelled up so what is this
all about so here's the back story Trump
has been talking about
hydroxychloroquine for a while now as a
possible game changer the big possible
cure for the virus and the truth is it's
one treatment that is being tested there
are some significant side effects it's a
high risk thing for people with certain
cardiac situations and there are
conflicting studies about is chloroquine
better than placebo and or the
established course of treatment or not
so Trump has been pretty irresponsible
in touting it constantly saying what do
you have to lose by trying it of course
some people potentially would lose their
lives by trying it people are trying to
stockpile it certain of Governors have
been picking it up there are shortages
for people who take the medication for
its actual approved conditions like
lupus and some others now every time
foul Qi has been asked about it in the
press in the past he will say something
like listen it's a good drug for some
conditions we don't have any data yet
that says it is actually effective for
coronavirus we need proper
randomized controlled trials for using
this medication on kovat 19 period but
when I saw this and I saw Trump
immediately jump in and prevent doctor
foul Qi from answering the question I
suspected there was more to it in case
in point in the few hours right after
last night's press briefing we got that
additional information over the weekend
on Saturday there was a heated fight in
the Situation Room
involving doctor foul Chi about
chloroquine and one of Donald Trump's
bomb throwers Peter Navarro was fully in
it and apparently furious with dr.
pouchy so this happened Saturday
afternoon Mike Pence was there dr. foul
she was there dr. Burks Jared Kushner
Chad Wolfe Steven Hahn and indeed Peter
Navarro was there he's a right-wing
economists and big-time trump
brown-noser when the topic of
hydroxychloroquine was brought up
Navarro got up and grabbed a big stack
of folders and dropped them onto the
table and everybody started looking at
the papers in the folders and Navarro
said here are copies of studies that
show that clearly chloroquine works to
treat coronavirus and Navarro was
pushing for the Trump administration to
talk about it just talk about it like it
works kraków talk about it like a proven
treatment this was too much for dr.
pouchy and dr. foul she rightly said
this is anecdotal this is not data these
are not RCTs randomized controlled
trials this is irresponsible we can't go
out and promote this like a treatment
studies that have been done have no or
poor control groups there are studies
that say this does not work so doctor
foul she is trying to do what a doctor
does not succumbing to political
pressure from a right-wing economists
which is what Pete Navarro is this
apparently set off Pete Navarro
he started angrily pointing to the pile
of folders saying that science not
anecdote Navarro raised this voice
accused dr. Fauci of trying to prevent
Trump's travel restrictions which is
crazy since dr. fowey from the beginning
praised those travel restrictions
this is apparently something that in the
room also got people looking confused
cuz most people in the room knew that
doctor foul tree had indeed been
praising the travel restrictions so
question one is is it common that people
are yelling at each other during the
Situation Room meetings about
coronavirus the answer is no this is
reportedly the first time that this
happened but we now have a backstory
that explains what we saw yesterday so
now knowing the backstory let's look at
it one more time
Trump praising hydroxychloroquine like a
miracle cure which it is not proven to
be reporter tries to get dr. fowey to
comment and doctor foul cheat not
allowed to answer the question so weigh
in on this issue of hydroxychloroquine
would you think about this and what
rouille chilling truly chilling because
we have a president concerned only with
the political response to the virus you
have an economic adviser Peter Navarro
concerned only with the optics of the
response and doing things to try to
bolster the stock market not actually
find and develop safe proven cures and
you now have a doctor literally being
silenced by Trump on the world stage
during a press briefing what if you
could read ten books in just one sitting
that's exactly what one of my favorite
apps lets you do it's called blinka
stand what they do is take thousands of
popular nonfiction books they condense
them down into text or audio that you
can consume in 15 minutes blinka snakes
sure that you're getting all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for there's
a full book you're thinking about buying
you can use blink Asst to get a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself by being able to soak up an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes
I recently checked out the book podcast
marketing strategy by daniel rolls and
Kieran Rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what I'm
doing really recommended blink east has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month and you get the
entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video